le grand départ ce matin pour ces 13
familles ils sont 49 au total 20 adultes
et 29 enfants prêts à embarquer dans ce
buste direction la côte pour des
vacances en famille pour certains c'est
une première tu sais où tu vas aller à
la Tranche-sur-Mer avant des
parents en vacances avec mes enfants
vous seriez parti seul avec vos enfants
s'il y avait pas eu cette organisation
là non non c'est difficile comment je
vais faire pour payer je travaille pas
donc c'est compliqué avec les secours
catholiques c'est gratuit moi seulement
j'ai payé 50 euros pour ça c'est la
première fois que j'ai pas je suis trop
contente c'est vraiment très bien parce
que ça coûte plus cher et avec ses coups
catholiques on peut faire voilà on peut
sortir
mettre notre famille ici on fait 5000
par famille
pour régler le coût de ses vacances
chaque famille apporte une petite
participation et fournit l'entièreté de
ses repas le reste est financé par le
Secours Catholique et l'Agence Nationale
des chèques-vacances ou par les aides
spécifiques de la CAF dont bénéficie
certaines familles un séjour de 8 jours
organisé chaque année par trois
bénévoles de l'association oui on fait
tous les ans au mois de juillet en effet
un groupe d'une cinquantaine de
personnes par au bord de la mer la
plupart des personnes ne portent pas en
vacances l'idée c'est de proposer un
temps de un temps de repos un temps de
vacances en famille justement parce que
du coup dans l'année ils ont pas
forcément bien le temps de s'occuper
d'eux de prendre de se poser et de
profiter un petit peu pour certains de
la merde parce qu'il y a certains qui
ont jamais été à la mer il y a des
enfants qui ont une dizaine d'années qui
sont voilà qui sont en France depuis
quelques années mais qui n'ont jamais
connu les vacances les vacances sereines
on va dire
ces familles passeront leurs vacances en
mobil-home dans deux campings de La
Tranche-sur-Mer et profiteront
d'activité sur place le but leur offrir
de l'évasion et du repos mais aussi
lutter contre l'isolement tant pour les
parents que pour les enfants